hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to turbo dismount I'm here
with my good buddy Bob who has never
played this game before right no much
likes one we could just recorded goat
simulator he never played it before and
it was the funniest thing I've ever seen
so he is also going to play turbo
dismount it's different than ghost
simulator because you won't be able to
actually control what's happening so you
just pit space you your meter up to go
speed and then you go so we'll start you
out something easy I got the original
loaded up just hit play surprise oh
goodness oh yes it is that's better than
what I was gonna say so Wow I should
stick with that I'm not exactly sure how
you win at turbo dismount anyway but
yeah that's what happened you didn't
make it up the rabbit this happens to
some people put some like California
cruising music is like a law I have to
get a royalty free version so we'll have
to sing it California oh that's alright
song is it today is Californian Jana
well eco to the home your dad sees his
butt crack that is a nice butt isn't
exactly the same as very much true yes a
perfect spongebob suit well and then a
nice little chisel Froggers well this is
not possible
no it's possible you just got to believe
you got to believe but jesus take the
wheel of your tricycle all I do rail the
Train
what Oh God God your face got buried
into the concrete there your choice goes
to be that trained by Bob good one good
one
it does not okay nice ballerina move I
want to see that in slow motion and
danten danten it's so beautiful
obviously closest to the action right
there
Oh like that pelvic thrust a violent
humping good no it feels good I like
this it's good it's good it's so happy
he does or is that confute I can't - all
go I lied he's still in it he's still in
it and he's dead
oh-oh you it what will you be able to go
hey don't let me question how you play
your games goodness oh I just pack them
in there really jam it in good good guy
like this let's go
no bigs attention it's my shoulders and
the tops of my arm
okay can you jump can you jump in the
bus birds can fly right this is look
like a fly ebert I uh
is it a flappy bird
how long we're gonna hold that like I
try to make sure that was officially
awkward silence and it was just like can
I can I have to have like a zoom in
there it's like like the Final Fantasy
sad music friendship over Oh God
oh wait bring home by bird as I doing
know what that's really really well I'm
trying to use my imagination in the game
that we're trying to observe because
it's a fun-filled adventure so it's some
point here you think that I danced it
later later later later later later
later later Laura more more more more
more and more more more more more more
more more more more more more more more
there look at that that's dancing for
like four that's dancing
for like four frames it's jackal jackal
holy [ __ ] that bounces a landing Wow
that might be look your boy might be the
only time anyone has ever landed
anything in turbo-boost yeah but my
spleen is like destroyed it slowly my
friend of deployed I think you might
have the blend damage after that head
watch this perfectly fine perfectly guy
yeah good
good eye really fine good